محمود هل سمعت بتصريح جالنت نعم هذا ما
يسمى باستراتيجيه شيطنه العدو هي نوع من
البروباجاندا او الاله الاعلاميه الحربيه
يتم فيها اختزال كل الصراع الى نقطتين و
قطبين رئيسيين الخير والشر يتجاهل هذا
الخطاب اي مطالب محقه لدى الخصم مثل
الحريه الكرامه الحق في العيش وانما يتم
تصويره كاملا كشر مطلق دون وجود اجهزه
مختلفه دون وجود عسكريين دون وجود مدنيين
يهدف هذا الخطاب الى امرين رئيسيين الاول
رفع معنويات القوات المهاجمه والثانيه
التاطير لارتكاب فضاع انسانيه وتمهيدها
امام الراي العام ل وبالتالي قبولها هنا
هذا العمل يلعب ضد الدبلوماسيه يغلق تماما
الباب امام الدبلوماسيه ويضع الطريق موحدا
واحدا فقط امام اله الحرب والتمهيد للدخول
في حلقه مفرغه من القتل وارتكاب الفضاءات
الانسانيه هذا ما شاهدناه في شقين من هذا
التصريح الاول نزع الانسانيه من الخصم هم
حيوانات بشريه والثاني هو اطلاق حصار مطلق
لا فيه كهرباء لا ماء الى اخره امام
الجميع لا يستثني مختلف الاجهزه سواء كانت
عسكريه او مدنيه